the ccsd return to school countdown
continues tonight
for students pre-k to third grade while
some parents are forward others
will not be sending their kids back into
the classrooms eight news now reporter
sally jaramillo shares more on school
zone safety and some parent concerns it
is important that
as we return to school we make sure that
the school zones are
safe some ccsd students will be
returning to in-person classes
march 1st and not only is safety
important in school
but outside of school too before we went
online
we had 41 children hit either on their
way to school or
on their way home andrew bennett with
the department of public safety reminds
drivers of three rules near schools
number one
is that if there are children in the
school zone if the lights are on
or 30 minutes before or after school
that indicates that it is an active
school zone
there are no u-turns in school zones and
as finally
the speed limit is determined by the
slowest car in the school zone it's
illegal to pass another vehicle in the
school zone
expect to see police looking for
speeders as well as pedestrian safety
enforcements
in the coming weeks my kids have
struggled mentally
and they have i mean i feel like we have
a pretty good home life
britney peterson knows it's important
for her kids to return
i do struggle with mental illness and
with
this i feel like it is creating a
trajectory of
mental illness in children john emmons
has three children
one in pre-k another in first and in
sixth grade
our concern right now is that
the schools have a lot of challenges
before them
um and then there's a lot of people out
there in the world that
aren't taking this seriously everybody's
gonna do what they feel right doing
just be cautious sally jerramillo eight
news now
there is a need for cross guards listen
to the 675 positions are currently
available
we have posted a link on our website
eightnewsnow.com